these are the shows that are happening
this week you see what time the the
bands are on stage and you literally tap
the Botany she's a new ticket she won't
there's no book in her card fees and
that's it so welcome to the dice office
where a star up says any one room but
it's quite a fun room Phil Hutchins is a
veteran music manager turned
entrepreneur he set up dice in September
this year and it's growing fast and
what's amazing is that we're getting
about a thousand people a day to start
owning up to it dice is more than a
ticketing service it's like a guide gigs
and musicians are reviewed and suggested
the idea being that dice will learn your
tastes and keep you ahead of the crowd
so only in London first we don't accept
all the shows our our guidance is like
these are the best gigs to go to in
London there's so much already happening
in London other companies do this
already but with dice there's no hidden
costs they deal directly with the
promoters and artists this isn't the
first time that ticketing service has
off the tickers out any booking fees
dice is also working to stop ticket
scalping that's where someone or a
company buys tickets and then sells them
for a higher price pocketing the extra
money cuz we tagged the tickets to the
phone and the person is actually buying
it it's impossible to resell well not
quite dice has its own function which
allows users to sell their ticket if it
can't make it to the gig did you know
that 20% of people don't turn up to a
gig when it rains and so hence the
waiting list and so the idea is that
with dice they can return the tickets
and little else and the witness can
actually grab them
the margins in selling mobile tickets
are wafer-thin even with booking fees
for dice it's about scale
once we Leila in London then we'll
quickly expand around the world with
mobile we have the proposition of having
billions of people with technology in
their pockets so um what we find a zone
that says space for like music Angus
Bennett Bloomberg London